plus the new Skoda Yeti our car Chester
inna says the Skoda Yeti has been around
for four years more than 260 thousand
have been sold
now the first-generation is getting a
facelift what's unusual is that there
will be two versions this is the most
important button here in the off-road
outdoor version press it and all systems
are set to off-road so now it's time to
put this Yeti through its paces up first
is driving through water no problem for
the Yeti with a ground clearance of 18
centimeters and affording depth of 30
centimeters even the biggest mud puddles
are no obstacle
we're testing the most powerful diesel
in the engine range the 2-liter 125
kilowatt TDI is equipped with permanent
all-wheel drive and a six-speed DSG
gearbox it has a top speed of 197 km/h
and the manufacturer says it consumes
6.3 liters per 100 kilometers
in Germany the majority of SUVs never
leave the road most drivers never give
them a chance to show what they're
capable of the Yeti can handle 60%
inclines going up and down
if the off-road mode is activated the
Clark falls down the hill without human
intervention
the driver need only steer and tap the
brakes now and then
and if you're off and away from level
ground Skoda offers a he'll hold control
and that's the tough outdoor version
but it has a more urbane stablemate yeti
city is the name of the nut so off-road
version what it lacks in
rough-and-tumble it makes up for in
refinement
the most striking difference in the
front is the honeycomb structure of the
lower air intake
and where the outdoors black plastic
rear shows off its toughness the city
version is also more elegant from behind
kotas yawn aleut says it's really just a
matter of taste as to whether customers
go for the city or the outdoor
technically both versions are identical
they have the same engine choices and
transmissions and they have the same
Road clearance but Skoda believes the
city variant will be slightly more
popular with about sixty percent of
buyers choosing time to take the city
for a spin this time with the smallest
gasoline engine and front-wheel drive a
manual 6-speed gearbox is standard but a
twin clutch shifter is available
department Amos says she was impressed
by the yetis off-road performance but
the city version provides a much
different experience when it's equipped
with the smallest most fuel-efficient
engine unfortunately there's no off-road
button here this model really is
designed for urban traffic the 77
kilowatt 1.2 liter gasoline engine burns
an average of 6 liters per 100
kilometers the tested model was standard
trim level costs around 20 1,800 euros
in Germany in the basic version the
smallest Yeti city can be had for less
than 19 thousand euros and that is the
yetis recipe for success for a
relatively low price you get a practical
SUV with plenty of room and
state-of-the-art technology
another new feature is the safety vest
holder under the seats
the Yeti is also the first Skoda model
to offer an optional rear-view camera
it has a roomy rear seat made up of
three individual parts boxes and
restraints in the trunk make it easy to
keep things from moving around the
middle seat back can be easily folded
down to form an armrest with cupholders
see this sums up forgetting adventure by
noting that there's little difference
between the city and outdoor versions
apart from their appearance and here she
likes the outdoor just a little better
since there's hardly any difference in
price about two hundred euros in the
base model penis would treat herself to
the off-road version football a anti-gun